[Music]
on today's show we talk about the guilt
of moving away from our parents
especially when they're elderly we talk
about the pain and grief associated with
infertility
we talk about facing a divorce concern
for our kids and our ex
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john delony show
i hope you are doing awesome happy day
after a holiday we are back
in the office and when you listen to
this i don't even know if you're
finishing a holiday who knows when this
thing's coming out
but just know that we're recording it
it's the day after a holiday
so here's what that means in my house
that means my wife and daughter were
gone
and it was a dude's weekend here's a
couple of things after a dude's weekend
when an old man and an 11 year old hang
out together
number one i played in the yard
out in the country in summertime in
tennessee
that means i'm covered in bug bites of
all different kinds
every part of my body's itching on fire
right now
and i've got medicine in my bag and i'm
choosing not to put it on
just because this is a reminder i sat
down in the yard james and i knew it
this is going to be an itchy fiery
terrible idea and i did it anyway
to try to be cool dad and that's what i
get and here's the thing
that essential oils can help with that
you know what i would never put
an essential oil on my body ever i might
eat them or something or whatever drink
them
i'll never never um the second thing
is this so my son i'd sent him in
to grab something out of our closet
and he called me and he said hey dad
come look at this and i saw a package
behind a thing behind a thing hidden in
my own closet i didn't even know it was
there
so i got up on a stool and i moved some
stuff around the top of the closet you
know it's the top of your parents closet
it just feels like magic and mystery and
all kinds of things that you never want
in your mind up there is always up on
top of the closet
so i was like i don't know what that is
that my wife must have hidden something
from me so i climb up on this
tool and there's a giant bag
of flaffy taffy's hidden from me
behind that was boxes of peeps
i don't know what infidelity looks like
in your home but in my house
it's hiding candy from an addict
and so i got it all down
and i showed her i ate almost all of it
i ate my body weight in laffy taffy
peeps
all right then i just got off the rails
we had cereal i was like hey hank you
just want to go
through a drive-through any random
drive-through will do
while we're on this cancer escapade
let's just pile it all up
so we did that i can't even tell you the
restaurant actually i can remember the
restaurant it was brutal
and so now i'm an itchy bloated
disgusting
mess bringing to you a health and
wellness podcast on how you can live
better more joyful more
whole lives so sometimes i
like to try things out like different um
counseling modalities different
diets and exercise programs and bring to
you my n equals one experience
experiences and sometimes
like to tragically destroy my digestive
system
for you the listener so here we are an
itchy
disgusting mess so if you want to be a
part of this show
if this is your first time just
listening how about this just stop
and then just go scroll back and listen
to a couple other episodes
and then come back and join us and
you'll get where we're coming from here
but if you'd like to be on the show we
talk about your mental health your life
your families your terrible laffy taffy
decisions give us a call at one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one
it's one eight four four six nine three
three two nine one you can hear it in my
face
i feel like my face is swollen with
sadness
i i think you can't hear it in my face
that probably wasn't the best way i
could have said that
you can hear it in my voice as it's
making its way out of my face
because that's in for most of us kelly
that's where our voices start in the
face
man this show is off to a rip roar and
start or you can go to
ramseysolutions.com
show to join it let's just stop right
while we're ahead you know we're not
even beheaded we are losing but let's go
out to faith the faith of faith we gotta
have faith in texarkana
texas and see what's up faith how are
you
i'm fine how are you i am so good did
you have a good weekend
i did i did glad to hear you did
i don't know i would call it a good one
but we survived it so hey what's going
on how can i help
yes yes my question is my husband and i
moved back to our hometown we've been
gone for over 20 years and moved back to
care for our elderly parents
you know we thought we'd be here maybe
three to five years and now we're going
on almost 10 years
so it's a very small rural community
where my husband is a pastor of a small
church
mostly elderly folks 70 and above we're
in our mid
50s and so we are kind of wanting to get
out of full-time ministry do something
different
and so we're looking at you know
congregations about 40 miles away
just to go there and also there's more
job opportunities there
but we're kind of feeling guilty about
you know wanting to leave and
you know should we stay as we originally
planned but we really don't want
those feelings to lead to resentment
towards our parents you know but we also
kind of feel like we're putting our
lives on hold
so how do you deal with those feelings
and should we stay here
should we you know just move to that
congregation and still stay in town to
be here for our parents you know
just kind of feeling the strain on our
marriage and dealing with those feelings
so as in is one of you already moved and
the other ones
got a foot in and a foot out and
basically yes
who who is who is the person so
um i you know i i've kind of been ready
to go for a while
okay yeah and so this is
this is a call about um your parents but
it's a call about your marriage too
right
yes yes and
one of those things that a day turns
into a couple of months turns into a few
years
turns into hey let's just do this and
suddenly you realize you've lost you
feel like you've lost a decade
right and then you're running out of
decades at 50 right it feels like it's
right
it does ugh man so i've got
a number of friends who are early 40s
through mid 50s
and these are folks i've worked with
these are like friends i went to college
with just buddies
and i can't tell you how many of them
are experiencing a similar thing
they live in the same town or within an
hour of their parents of their aging
parents if you will
and they felt this need to
not move grandkids make sure they're all
there make sure that
it's it's this almost imaginary thing
going on so
my first question for you is what do you
offer your parents besides being down
the street do they need you
um one of my parents is going through
chemo right now okay for cancer so
um that keeps us you know pretty busy um
you know
and and there's one set of parents
basically that would you know
i mean they're all like i said 70s 80s
they're doing
the other three are doing fairly well
and says some of them would not you know
they would be fined if we
if we left if we went but then there's
some that would
let's just say i i don't know they're
kind of very demanding
so i don't know how they would you know
accepted or not accepted or how they
would
you know feel about it
so at the end of the day here's the
direct
yet harsh yet direct truth
if you and your husband are not on the
same page
if you all are not doing the things you
need to do to take care of yourselves
financially
um experientially if your marriage is
heading towards the sands of the beaches
of resentment
you're no good taking care of anybody
and
i've got loved ones i've got friends who
have given up
years and decades and driven back and
forth and back and forth
to make sure mom and dad get to stay in
the same town we'll give up our
40s and 50s and sometimes even 60s to
make sure
this and that would mom and dad move
absolutely not it's our job
and suddenly just implodes on everybody
and so here's how i would handle this if
i were you actually
i've been in a somewhat similar
situation i've got aging parents they're
both still working but i've got aging
parents and my wife and i packed up and
left the state three or four years ago
um we just moved
hours and hours and hours away a couple
of reasons one
um i would love for my parents to move
in with us someday that'd be great or
move around us or be a part of that
my job right now is to take care of my
wife and my kids the best that i can
and number two um i've got brothers and
sisters who can help out
also do you or your husband have
brothers and sisters that help out too
are y'all only children no we we do have
siblings that help out but
but none of them live in in the area so
they they do what they can
but as far as coming very often you know
they're not able to do that
so why why are you two the only ones who
can step up in this way
i guess because we decided to move here
we were the ones that decided well we'll
move there and we'll be there for
because we knew our parents wouldn't
leave their hometown
so it was just you know we were at that
point our kids had both left home
and were off and um got married so we
just said well we don't have any ties to
where we were at so we moved here and
gotcha and um just for a minute so think
of it this way
okay your parents your in-laws their
decision to never move
no matter what that's a boundary that is
a
choice that they make and good for them
they have roots in that community
probably really deep roots if it's a
rural texas community man they
they are plugged in you
and your husband have a
right to your own relational boundaries
and that might mean
for the next 10 years we're gonna go
live in a city wheels off
we're going to go dancing every night
we're going to go get new jobs we're
going to reinvent ourselves which my mom
and dad did at 50 and 60. um and they've
inspired me just to keep dreaming and
thinking and pushing and prodding
and if and when your mom and dad need
you
y'all can have that conversation then
that conversation may look like
hey mom and dad we're going to sell the
place and we're going to move you all
into
a home closer to us or we're going to
get you a condo or an apartment or
you're going to move in downstairs where
y'all can have those conversations then
right
but yeah i i don't feel like you have
this obligation you know here's the
problem with boundaries
they're going to be really hurt and sad
and disappointed and frustrated and let
you know how much you let them down
right and if you don't move you're going
to be hurt and disappointed and let down
and really frustrated that
you let yourself down or your husband
trapped you or fill in the blank with
what other
issues you're going to create right
right and so i don't see a situation
where you can't go
okay especially 40 miles away that i
mean that's close
if you're talking 20 hours away i'd
still say go
um but you may have to have a broader
conversation with your brothers and
sisters
um right quite honestly a conversation
with your brothers and sister
is necessary anyway to let them know hey
we are
drying up in this town um the work is
not great
um we've got jobs in these other places
and we're going to be heading out
and so we're going to all need to
reimagine what care for
mom and dad look like and care for
in-laws look like
everyone's got to pitch in financially
everyone's got to pitch in time-wise
we're going to need some
rotations everyone's gonna have to be in
on this um because we're gonna go
take new jobs in a new town and yes
there's gonna be drama there's gonna be
this is and that's but at the end of the
day there's gonna be this isn't that's
anyway you're at a pick your poison
place in life do you want to pick
resentment for your marriage and your
relationships or do you want to
pick resentment on your parents or just
want to go live wide open
and when they need you they'll call and
then you can have some hard
life shifting conversations then but i
say move i say go i say put
take the top off whatever old car you
got just saw it off
and drive that 40 miles let your hair
back
y'all been living in a small rural town
for a decade now
and i think it's time to go live for a
few years thank you so much for that
call faith
let's go to cynthia in medford oregon
hey cynthia what's going on
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
this morning you bet how are you
i'm i'm doing pretty good um we're
blessed and
so i'm i'm grateful to be on your show
today too awesome
so anytime somebody starts something
with
i'm blessed tells me they're not doing
great
but they're trying to smile their way
through something am i on to say
am i right yes sir
that's the same as when someone says hey
look at tommy over there oh bless his
heart
you know something awful is about to
come about him um
so hey so what's going on
well sorry i promised myself i wasn't
gonna cry on here um
my husband and i have been trying to
start a family for about seven years
and i'm so sorry it's been
a rough road i have some fertility
issues
and we've done everything we can
short of you know thousands and
thousands of dollars of
procedures and things but um even then i
had
weight loss surgery um and lost 140
pounds because that was causing some of
the fertility issues
wow good for you what a stud
it's been amazing and um
oh excuse me oh you're good you're good
hey take your time go ahead take your
time
we got to go ahead and start trying
again in october and
everyone said you know weight loss will
expedite fertility my sister
had had weight loss surgery and she
stopped at the birth control was
pregnant the next month
now she's on baby number three um
and that just hasn't happened for us
um normally
normally i can um deal with the
anger and heartbreak and prayer and
journaling and
some hard conversations with my husband
who's absolutely amazing
um that lately that hasn't been the case
anymore
i am i teach sunday school and i work
with kids a lot
and i start crying at random times and i
have to excuse myself
um when my sister told me she was
pregnant for the third time
this one was unplanned and they'll have
three under four
um and so she wasn't super excited but
um they're they're blessed
and i i left the dinner early because
i couldn't keep myself together and i
heard her feelings that she
understands what we're going through um
but it took me a couple days to be happy
for her
sure and i i want to be happy for my
friends and my family who were
blessed this way that my normal coping
skills are just not working
yeah i'm so
so sorry cynthia
no don't be sorry at all i'm sorry
you had this extraordinary picture of
what life was going to look like
and i can tell by your the way you care
for other people
you'd be an extraordinary mother
extraordinary friend extraordinary wife
man i'm so sorry
thank you so first off you don't need to
apologize for hurting real bad
okay it feels like after
seven years and big surgery and
really going the extra mile working
really hard on your heart on
yourself and on your body and on your
marriage
and then yet you're looking at another
what almost a year
that in some ways it's the reality this
is starting to sink in on you is that
true
yeah very much so
and it's that running running running
running running and then suddenly
you can stop and you drop your shoulders
and exhale big and go oh my gosh is this
my life
i think it's starting to hit that this
this might not happen for us
um i've been able to just say well i'll
try again next month or
it'll happen eventually and i know i'm
not super old
i'm 34 so it could still happen but oh
you're a baby
but listen but listen listen
this is the worst and there's something
really important about
dropping your shoulders just sitting in
it for a minute you've been sprinting
for seven years
really hard
and it's just tiring and exhausting and
frustrating
and you probably have a room picked out
in your house that you walk by and it's
still empty
is that right yep
and dude if another person
instagrams oh my gosh number four right
yes yeah i have a sister and a
sister-in-law
that um are both unexpectedly pregnant
one at 40
and one who just had you know two in two
years and
it's just sure man why not hey while
we're laying down how about everybody i
know and love
just come over and kick me that'd be fun
that's kind of how it feels and i know
that that's not that's not what they
plan and i
i just want to be happy for them but
some days it's real rough
yeah so grief
um grief's like sitting on a raft in the
ocean
right and sometimes it is so still
and peaceful and you see the sun coming
up and birds are flying overhead and
it's just
simply this awe-inspiring moment
and sometimes grief is a giant wave that
knocks you over
and then you get sucked under by the
undertone you don't know if you're going
to be able to come back out and because
you can't breathe
right and it never kills you but man it
feels like it's about to
and then all of a sudden you look up and
two people that you do care about you do
love and you do
you are genuinely excited for them right
they've
got tears in their eyes because suddenly
it's a whole thing now and all that so
a couple of thoughts here i've lived
this okay
on my side of it i i can never speak to
what someone who wants to be a mom feels
like um
but man i've sat there and watched
a hurt that i i didn't have words for
and
um i have felt that man that empty
that long walk down the hallway i know
that room's empty down there i just see
i know it is
and um
so here's a couple of things number one
your grief is your grief is your grief
and if you haven't already i think it's
time for a conversation no you know what
you probably have so tell me about this
what is a conversation been like when
you sit down with your husband whether
y'all are on a date y'all are just
laying there in the middle of the night
you can't sleep
and y'all have the what do we do if this
doesn't work conversation
what's that been like
um it's a little complicated um
i've always thought of adoption would be
a great way i
i know i have a lot of love in my heart
and it doesn't have to be my kid
necessarily
but my husband had a really rough
childhood
and he's a felon um the lord saved him
probably i think
11 or 12 years ago so he is the most
wonderful man
um but that by itself would cause us a
really big struggle um i'm not sure if
that is something that that would
completely keep us from adopting but i
think it might
um and
i i i feel some guilt that this is my
fault
and uh hold on the idea of putting him
through that struggle and being told no
because of
him i know but listen i'm gonna ask you
not to do that to yourself
okay this is a heartbreak situation not
in my fault situation
okay i know he says the same thing he's
been so supportive and loving it's
it's annoying and frustrating at how
supportive he's being i know
you just want him to be pissed off and
angry and smashed up so you can both
hate and be mad and angry together
and that's not the guy you married he's
a good guy and so just some strange
random dude on the other side of the
country i'm telling you
your feelings are valuable right they
they have value to them they're legit
the feeling of anger super real and
honest
the feeling of being um
raged out that everyone around you is
having kids it feels like they're not
but it feels that way
legit the the
the feeling of guilt that this is your
fault it's a real feeling
but it's not true okay
okay it's not true and one important
thing that i always ask folks to do is
get all those feelings out on the table
and then just mine them for evidence
just demand evidence from them is that a
true statement feel them
accept them but then be able to sit down
and say is this one true
and um you can get all into the
mechanics at all under the weeds and
only if only and then you're gonna look
at your husband and say what i'm denying
him this
man here's the thing that is a futile
road to travel okay
there is nothing that comes of that road
at all
except ash okay um
he is probably grieving too and so
here's a couple things i want you to do
i'll circle back
number one i want you all to have a
planned conversation
a planned real truthful conversation
that's on the calendar that you both
know is coming
that's going to be about what if
what are we actually going to do if we
look up
and a year from now we're not pregnant
i want you to get some real data about
the
adoption process what does that actually
look like because right now it's just a
pipe dream it's just a
i think it's gonna be really hard or
it's not gonna be really hard it's going
to be really expensive
get some actual true firm data and even
before that
ask him if he actually wants to adopt
right is that something a journey he
wants to go down to
and you're going to find some some
differences some assurances some i don't
know
all that kind of stuff is going to come
out there too but make sure you're on
the same page and then the third thing
is give each other space to grieve this
thing
and grief's going to look different for
everybody
for you it may be don't work with kids
for a season
right when i was working crisis um
and i had a little baby seven or eight
month old daughter
i wouldn't work child cases i just
wouldn't do it i couldn't
and then still be well and still be
whole and be able to work that scene
appropriately and go home and be present
with my daughter appropriately i
couldn't do it
and so i had to opt out of small infant
child cases
and it was just for a season now i can
my kid's older
but i probably wouldn't show up to a six
or seven or eight year old right now
because i got a six and seven eight year
old right right and so
it may be a season that you put some
space between you and bait within
and working with little babies with
little kids give yourself an opportunity
to heal
okay and not heal like it's not gonna
hurt not like that
but heal so that you can breathe
normally
that you can rediscover the joy in kids
and not that
pain right not that mirror walking up to
what you don't have
and if you can't make it to a an event
and a dinner
you don't know anybody an explanation
you owe them a hey we can't make it
tonight we'll be there next time
all right or we'll do our best to be
there you don't need to put an excuse
you don't need
nothing and you don't have to i mean you
don't have to apologize you can just
totally own that thing
right you can just own it why because
it's your life and it's your boundaries
and it's your relationship and it's your
husband and y'all go to cracker barrel
in the middle of night if that's what
you want to do you'll get diabetes and
that probably would be good but
um you can go eat wherever you want to
go you can go do what you want to do
right you don't owe anybody explanations
for things
you can get off instagram you can get
off facebook you don't have to see every
birth announcement show up to every uh
what do they call them the
when they poof like pink and blue
powder into the gender reveal yeah
whatever those things are you don't do
any of that crap you have to do any of
it
right but that comes from
healing that comes from grieving deeply
that comes from acknowledging the
reality of where we are
seven hard hard years
just sitting in that for a bit feeling
it
riding those waves and they're big and
messy and heavy
and so annoying and they come out of the
blue and they drag us under water but
they don't kill us they never do
then we pop back out and then you see
that former felon turned incredible
husband's arm reaching down to pull you
out of the water and sometimes you're
gonna pull him out
and then y'all gonna own what tomorrow
looks like you're gonna figure it out
but you can only do that if you are
grieving together letting each other
grieve whatever hey he may grieve by
just being a weirdo and want to get
video games
don't let him do that by the way but
everybody grieves different
and he may grieve by reading dumb
science articles and he may grieve by
feeling the blank filling blank you're
both going to do it differently be so
graceful with each other
so graceful and then yeah own what
tomorrow looks like
write that new narrative and figure it
out if that's adoption if that's
fostering if that
is being the greatest aunt and uncle of
all time
if that is being a full-time rando
babysitter for folks who can't afford
babysitting in your local community
whatever that looks like for you
own it rock it deal with those ups and
downs when you get frustrated and sad
you'll grieve this for the rest of your
life
it'll be something right it'll be hard
and painful and
there's beauty and joy on the other side
of this
you just gotta ride out those storms
i'm so so sorry but i'm so grateful how
brave you are
so grateful your husband loves you i'm
grateful you love him and i'm grateful
for your heart and
person you are in your local community
and they're lucky to have you
at the end today so so sorry that you're
going through this
we love you keep us posted on what comes
next let us know how that grieving
conversation goes and how
acknowledging conversation goes and
we'll be thinking about you
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that
everyone has anxiety i've been there and
so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's
not and how you can get back on the road
of being whole
and well listen you are not broken
and i'm living proof that you can get
your life back
i wrote this book so everyone could read
it not just science nerds like me and my
friends
and i priced it at 10 bucks so that
everyone can afford it this little book
landed on the best seller list and is
now being purchased by the case
and given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country
i don't care if you're a teenager or an
executive or a 75 year old grandmother
this book is for everyone so go to
johndeloney.com and get your copy of
redefining anxiety today
let's take one more call let's go to
daryl in johnson city tennessee daryl
what's going on brother
i'm doing good how are you doctor john
i'm doing all right my man
you sound down this morning how are
things
oh it's good i i work third shift so you
know i'm a little tired
[Laughter]
always glad to talk to you well always
glad to talk to you even though it's our
first time so what's up man
uh yeah my question is um me and my
ex-wife are recently going through
divorce
and i just want to know how it could
still be there for her
and my children man so give me the
details brother
oh well i'd say we were together for
about
you know eight years we have two
beautiful kids
and uh then you know
we of course had issues like every
marriage
and we decided to separate
and then we decided did something happen
uh it's more of me being dumb and
in the marriage and what does that mean
problems and
i do i uh decided to ask uh another
female
about uh my marriage problems and you
know
that uh caused a lot of issues
and did you cheat on your wife no
but i mean in the way me talking to
another woman is
infidelity but we didn't i didn't cheat
but you know
in a way that is cheating okay and so
ultimately
but that that that happens
in fact i don't know many marriages
where that doesn't happen in some shape
form or fashion so
that in and of itself wouldn't lead to
divorce what was the
decision you guys came to that said hey
where i'm out
uh it was more of we were always better
friends than we were married
and we decided that
we would rather be separated and be a
united front for our children
than be married in fight old time
didn't y'all decide just to not fight
all the time
i don't know you know we could we could
be in a room and you know within
10 minutes we'll get on each other's
nerves and just start fighting
nobody yeah we didn't but you you you
made the decision to
dissolve your family unit and
that's hard and painful and incredibly
expensive
and a beating and grief
filled and all those things would
wouldn't it have been easier just to
like
decide to not fight it
it would have or just be like not about
that hey why don't i just respect you
and be kind
and sure we can watch that movie or sure
i'll quit eating that or whatever the
thing is i won't
fart in the living room i don't know
what your things were but
man yeah so is this thing is this a done
deal
it's over yeah it's it's definitely done
deal
you know where uh we go to court soon
afford it
to uh get it finalized um
and there's no going back i mean you
haven't get you haven't given me any
you're calling to ask how you can love
your wife your soon to be ex-wife
well and you're calling me to
ask how you can honor and love your kids
during the separation and while they
move into a different home or whatever
the custody arrangement will be
and you haven't given me any reason at
all
as to why y'all just kind of cashed it
out
other than you quit putting gas in the
car and then it slowly just sputtered
and stopped and instead of filling it
with gas y'all just said that let's just
leave it on the side of the road
you go that way i'll go this way you
haven't given me anything
you know what i mean yeah
like it sounds like you really still
like this lady
oh i mean yes i do still love her you
know
she's moved on um you know i've
i guess i haven't moved on but you know
i'm in a process
of you know trying to move past it and
you know try to be there for my kids you
know
so one of two things brother and then
i'll then i'll answer your question
either there's something big going on
here that you're not telling me which is
fine you don't have to
or there is a major major conversation
that's
been left unsaid there is a hard
conversation
that one of you said hey why don't we
just do this and then someone said yeah
we were better off this way anyway and
what about that and it's for the kids
and partridge in the pear tree
and suddenly both of you guys are
walking like the
like those movies where the person keeps
looking back
right when the other person turns their
head and the other person looks back
right the other person turns their head
and then y'all just kept on walking
and so here's what i'll tell you we've
all heard stories about
folks meeting at the courthouse to go
finalize divorce and they just go to
breakfast and
make sure everybody's on the same page
and suddenly they say what are we doing
and if it's not too late i'll tell you
right now
i don't care if she's quote unquote
moved on are you quote-unquote moved on
y'all been together a decade man
she's a part of you and if there's a
shred of you that says hey man is this
the only
last nuclear option do we have to hit
this button
call her up and say hey do we have to
hit this button because man it is
way way easier to decide to quit
fighting
that's an easy easy it's a simple easy
thing to do
it's hard but it's simple right
and you can re-change you can i mean
re-program yourself on how you talk to
one another and how you love each other
and how you show up for each other
and you're getting a bird's-eye view of
what the other side of this thing looks
like and it
sucks right yeah
yeah because i always told myself you
know when i got married i was gonna get
divorced because you know
my parents when i was you know younger
they
divorced as well but that didn't go uh
good at all no it never does man it
never does
yeah yeah and i was like you know
i'm gonna try my best and you know it
you know went sideways and
now we're divorcing but you know i told
them you know i'm gonna at least
you know get along with her you know
co-parents
and make sure that you know my kids know
they are loved and
we are both there for them
that cut i get that and it's it's
honorable that that's your approach
i get that but part of me sounds like
you
are
about to push a button to launch a
missile
and you're letting folks know hey i'm
gonna sweep up
all the damage i'm gonna clean it up
really nice
i promise i'm gonna sweep up all the
glass
and the metal and all the bodies i'm
gonna sweep all that up i will be a good
cleaner
and i feel like just saying like
you have to hit the button that's all
i'm asking so
man i'll tell you right now i've heard
it more than once there's a shred of you
that says hey can we still make a go at
this thing call your wife
before she becomes your ex-wife and take
her out somewhere and have that hard
conversation
if it is what it is and that thing's a
foregone conclusion
here's how you um be there for your ex
and for your kids
you be there for your ex and for your
kids
see the challenge is you're going to get
divorced and you're going to have to end
up doing the things and working on the
things that would have kept you married
in the first place
you're gonna have to choose to not be
frustrated when she does the things that
make you annoyed and she's gonna have to
choose the same thing also
you're gonna have to choose to never try
to quote unquote win an engagement with
her
it's gonna always be about how can you
demonstrate that she's a person of value
and dignity in front of your children
and
not in front of your children you have
to treat her that way always talk
positively about her
don't fight and yell and scream because
fighting yelling screaming
only ends up in piles of bodies it's a
complete waste of time and energy
most of the time unless there's a major
abuse or
you know drug use or breaking the law
things like that
and so at the end of the day you have to
choose to honor this woman
and for some reason you chose to walk
away from her instead of honoring her
the first time so you've got to figure
out how to do all these things anyway
and when it comes to your kids you're
going to have to make sure
beyond a shadow of a doubt that you show
up you never miss
you never miss don't
bring a parade of other people through
their life until you are confident that
somebody is stable and has their best
interest in mind as well
make sure that you and your wife can
show up to parent conferences together
that y'all can show up to
mother and to i mean school plays
together things like that
you're gonna have to be in each other's
lives you're gonna have to be yeah
and you're gonna have to probably go see
somebody and work on
your childhood stuff you're the
separation from your parents that you're
still rattling around in your head
that's still a point of hurt and failure
for you
you have to choose to not be angry
you're gonna have to choose to be a
person who
just lets things go right that's called
wisdom and maturity and
growth you probably have to get your
butt in a gym
and learn how to be physically able to
take care of yourself to honor your own
body because you don't think you do
right
now you're gonna have to do all of these
things and so here's what
i'm telling you right that's a tall list
it's a tall order
you basically have to re re-imagine how
you live daryl and then go make it
happen
here's the cool thing i know that you
can you wouldn't be calling me if you
weren't interested in that i know that
you can
yeah and i know that your kids are worth
it and now you're committed to not
replaying the life that you were given
early on in your road
right yeah that one that told you
hey mom and dad broke up and it's
probably somewhat a little bit tiny bit
your fault
and they didn't uh stay connected
because
you mean you really got in the way there
right whatever that message is
dad wanted away from her so bad that he
ended up getting away from you too or
whatever the story that you still tell
yourself
at the end of the day it's not your
fault you're gonna have to work through
that stuff and
man if there's a chance work through it
with a partner work through it with
somebody who's been ride or die for 10
years
maybe not maybe i'm too optimistic man
but i can tell you i don't know a
marriage that hasn't had a crossroads
that says hey this is this
is probably not working out for us or
why'd we even do this or what are we
doing
or i crossed this line or she crossed
that line or whatever whatever
that can't get in a room and say hey i
said
forever and if you still mean forever
we'll figure this out
because you're gonna have to figure it
out anyway or that
forest fire of trauma goes to the next
generation
and the next generation and the next
generation and so on and so forth
to daryl thanks so much for that call
brother thank you for being a brave guy
not a lot of guys would get on the air
and talk with me like you did so i'm
grateful for you
thanks for your willingness to clean up
the mess after y'all make it
and at least on my behalf thank you for
considering one last time
do i have to push this button is this
thing a foregone conclusion have i
screwed up this bad
is she that unlikable unlovable
that we can't get in a room probably
with a therapist and figure this thing
out
i'll be rooting for you man rooting for
you rooting for you
and if this thing is final if y'all do
go to the courthouse together and sign
those papers
walk out in that parking lot and look
each other eye and say from this point
forward
we are friends we honor one another we
treat each other with dignity
and we love these kids more than they
will ever understand until they have
their own kids
right that's the narrative and that's
the story
oh thank you so much for that call
brother all right um
let's do this one
back in the day back in high school we
had this little bitty uh
movement that swept through
punk clubs everywhere these punk clubs
these punk rock bands showed up with
their
orchestra friends their friends bringing
trumpets and and trombone
probably a recorder here or there
probably not
and man i got swept up in the ska
movement i loved him they brought so
much
joy to this hard punk that i was
listening to
i love love scott here's the thing i am
going to say this out loud and this is
going to be me
being honest with you all ska is the
only time you're allowed to play a
fender
that's it that's it because you need
that
jangle dangle dangle jangle papa pop pop
i love it so the greatest goss song of
all time
and listen ska people are a little bit
territorial like people who worship
their diets
and religions but guys this is the song
that broke it you gotta just deal with
it
off the 1997 let's face it album the
mighty mighty bostones
dropped the big one that changed
everything
the song the impression that i get is
the greatest ska song of all time except
for
most songs by real big fish but that's a
whole other conversation
and it goes like this have you ever been
close to tragedy or been close to folks
who have
have you ever felt a pain so powerful so
heavy you collapse
no well i've never had to knock on wood
but i know someone who has which makes
me wonder if i could
it makes me wonder if i've never had to
knock on wood
and i'm glad i haven't yet because i'm
sure it isn't good
that's the impression that i get
such a great line i've never had to
knock on wood
i'm glad i haven't yet because i'm sure
it isn't good that's the impression that
i get
they're writing a song about not ever
having a bad thing happen
what a great song that mighty mighty
boss tones and this has been
the dr john daloni show
you